messieurs vous avez vous nous avez fait
part de vos difficultés
à avoir des conditions de travail
correctes notamment au port de dégrad
des cannes et au port fluvial de saint
laurent les autorités ne vous répondent
pas en tout cas juste pour vous dire que
je suis à votre disposition pourront
plus travailler avec le avec les
différents partenaires comme le grand
port maritime en fait tous ceux qui la
chambre de commerce et ses tempêtes pour
pouvoir trouver des solutions à cette
problématique des chiens quand même un
souligné nous nos difficultés par
rapport à ces à ses différents
départements les premières ce sont
les complicités de devoir desservir ces
départements je pense à la guyane que je
dis que je vient de balayer la guyane
aujourd'hui
dégrad-des-cannes le port de dégrad des
cannes et un port est compliqué
adc revient au quoi parce qu'aujourd'hui
on manque d'infrastructures et surtout
au manque d'eau pour entrer avec nos
navires donc plus vous allez avoir de
demandes sur la guyane plus nos
difficultés vont apparaître du fait du
manque d'eau de tirant d'eau parce que
pour rentrer dans le port de dégrad des
cannes on a un tirant d'eau d'environ
six mètres cinquante dépendant de la
rare et et ça on devra vivre aiac cas ce
que je pense que dans l'avenir on n'a
pas de projet très clair de la part des
autorités pour
améliorer le tirant d'eau de dégrad des
cannes et fournir en plus de l'outillage
pour pouvoir décharger de l'ariège
faucon sachez qu'en guyane ont des
charges nous navire avec nos grue de
bord il n'y a pas de portiques ni le gru
sur le quai pour pouvoir décharger ou
charger nos conteneurs ce qui
complexifie l'escale puisqu'on on met du
temps à décharger ce sont des opérations
qui sont compliqués et donc du fait de
l'augmentation des volumes on a de plus
en plus de difficultés à faire nos
escales à tenir les horaires de nos
escales donc on rallonge les horaires de
nos escales est finie man on dégrade les
les services dans leur ensemble donc il
faut qu'on arrive à trouver
des solutions pour la guyane on en
discutera je pense après ensemble on a
bien évidemment
l'intention de concentrer à accompagner
la croissance si on est bien une somme
100 m à force on est bien et on pourra
parler avec vous et échanger avec vous
je l'espère du futur de la guyane et on
parlera j'espère de saint laurent du
maroni
qui pour nous permettrait de désengorger
est gratuit et pouvoir continuer à
accompagner la croissance de la guyane
ça c'est très important